Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is press my favorite audio book of all time,
and that is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished,
it's amazing.
You will thank me.
The graveyard book.
The second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour workweek.
So all you need to do to get your free audio book and a Free 30 Day trial is go
to audible.com forward slash Tim and you can choose one of those two books,
the graveyard book vagabonding or more than 180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book.
That could be a magazine,
that could be a newspaper,
could be a class.
It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim,
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a book.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by me undies.
If I'm not going commando,
I'm in Mandy's.
I have been testing these underwear for three to four months now pretty much
every day and in fact throughout bunch of my other underwear this morning and on
the road in the house,
they are extremely comfortable.
They look good,
feel good.
They are made of micro model two times softer than cotton as scientifically
tested using the [inaudible] method.
Sounds very fancy of course,
and I get a lot of compliments from ladies for these.
You don't get diaper butt,
you don't get the tired elastic band.
They look great and they have underwear for both men and women.
Check out [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim and you can see everything that
I've been wearing.
They're ridiculous.
The sublime,
everything in between,
including my favorite,
which is called out and I would be remiss if I didn't mention their lounge
pants.
This is a new thing and I have been wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcast.
I've been wearing them out and about when I'm walking the dog meeting people for
coffee.
And they are extremely comfortable though.
They're made from the same material as the underwear,
but some of them like the blue ones,
I have have pockets so you can walk about without seeming like you're off of
your meds and completely crazy.
So that is awesome.
And if you're not happy with the first pair you try on,
I assume that refers to the underwear,
they'll refund you completely and you can keep the pair you tried on for free.
But if you're that kind of person,
you should be ashamed because that's disgusting.
Uh,
[inaudible] dot com slash Tim,
check it out.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
And welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I've had a bit wine to drink and by a bit,
I mean two bottles with a friend of Pleiades by Sean Factory,
which I highly recommend.
This show is usually about deconstructing worldclass experts and this episode is
no exception,
although instead of a chess prodigy or a military strategist or an entertainment
icon,
we have perhaps the best storyteller.
And Pitch Man I've ever had on this show.
Uh,
certainly he would give cal Fussman a run for his money and he is none other
than Mike Rowe,
a micro you may know from dirty jobs,
but I'm going to read his bio except had enough to drink and this is on
micro.com and having spent some time with Mike.
Now this is a,
this is very fitting.
Here we go.
I'm going to read the entire paragraphs.
So bear with me.
I in this episode I will say is so worth listening to and its entirety because
we cover how to sell a pencil.
QVC,
the meaning of freelance,
the business and Mike Rowe,
his mentors.
We talk about some of his favorite,
uh,
influences and mentors.
We talk about favorite books,
we talk about the art of voiceover.
We talk about Bruno Mars and how he became Bruno Mars.
We talked about Orson Welles.
It goes on and on and on.
I had a blast with this and just got back from spending some time after the
interview with Mike and I hope we have a part two and 0.3.
Oh Jesus.
I'm with somebody next to me and they're admiring my state of inebriation.
Here we go.
Micro from the web site is a TV host,
writer,
narrator,
producer,
actor,
and spokesman.
His performing career began in 1984 when he faked his way into the Baltimore
Opera to get his union card and meet girls.
And that is true,
both of which he accomplished during a performance of Rigoletto is transition to
television.
Occurred in the,
in 1990 when to settle a bet.
He auditioned for the QVC shopping channel and was promptly hired after talking
about a pencil for nearly eight minutes there.
He worked the graveyard shift for three years until he was ultimately fired for
making fun of products and be the little [inaudible] viewers.
So all of that is true and we dig into it and you should say hi to Mike on
either end or Twitter.
And I'm flipping through pages because I've had too much to drink at.
Uh,
Mike Rowe works.
That's Twitter at Mike Rowe works or on Facebook.
He's Burke.
Wow.
Just gets better and better.
Uh,
the real Mike Rowe,
uh,
this was a blast of a conversation that I've wanted to have for 15,
20 years and I hope you enjoy it.
So say a little Mike.
And without further ado,
here is my conversation with the inimitable Mike Rowe.
Mike,
Welcome to the shelf.
I think you mean welcome to your living room.
Welcome to the esteem studio of Tim Ferriss enterprises.
I e.
My living room,
sophisticated,
understated with a certain insouciance in dare I say an Asian influence.
I,
that's actually my Tinder description,
not just
converting pretty well.
I have wanted to have the chance to sit down with you for many years and I
wanted to thank you right off the bat.
I'm not sure if I mentioned this when we met,
which we'll get to for the first time,
but you helped keep me sane for a period of several years when I had an
extremely punishing job from about 2000 to 2002 specifically.
That was,
that was when I was logging the most hours and I would come home and there were
two shows.
It was dirty jobs.
Uh,
so you,
and then Jeff Corwin who were like my,
my,
my tele therapists.
And so I just want to,
to thank you for putting out good work.
Well,
you're welcome.
I mean,
look,
when people say things could always be worse,
um,
it means whatever you decided means,
but then when you can actually turn on the TV and see some sort of optical
manifestation of what worse is.
Well there you go.
You know,
reinforcement.
I remember,
I remember one episode in particular,
I remember several episodes of course,
but one came to mind.
I had seen you do,
do really,
really dirty stuff.
There was one where I think you were winterizing a boat and you or you just look
so bored out of your mind.
And I just remember thinking exactly what you said.
I was like,
you know,
sitting in the fire exit,
violating code at this startup,
being unable to move,
sleeping under my desk.
Those are all hard things,
but at least I'm not doing that.
I'm not wrapping a boat.
Yeah.
That was,
um,
Manhattan beach,
oddly named since we were in Cincinnati on the river.
And it was,
I think,
late November and all of the pleasure crafts down there,
you know,
are obviously vulnerable and susceptible to the,
to the climate in a huge way.
I mean,
they'll just crack.
It just gets so cold and a team.